hello and welcome to this video playing
Tim Wakefield i am tim league field it's
a new account only playing a couple of
five in one minute so why is my clock
running what i did make a pre move there
that's weird okay so let's see what we
get here against mr. Wakefield and just
not the it's not the real name but ok so
and this is a line that I have phone
recently studied for black it's not
super exciting normally aimed at I'm
equalizing the game but in most cases
black is succeeding with that so not a
bad line do we almost though I'm sure
I'm just forgetting after castling do I
go see 5 or do I go nite bd7 I think it
not be t7s right ya nabi t7s right we
need to be should be seven
yeah leg will go see five eventually but
I have time with them if I don't need to
do it quickly Knight c3 that's actually
kind of uncommon in this position why
players are normally unprofor set up
with night to d2 as far as I remember
huh so what is the point if I cheek and
it's steak night eeks he wants to
sacrifice maybe yeah now that I think of
it there could be some point to that
yeah that could be an issue we should be
six and ninety-six both are kind of
interesting
let's let's do the sidestep hunter also
cover b7 for the moment I'm also
threatening Knight b6 now just a and 195
okay he covered covered against that
just canceling now I guess don't think
that night is success it's dangerous
probably just wants to go look see one
now meow okay look a bit of the sea fowl
and go for queen bee aids next yeah okay
need this side step here I cannot stay
on the C file I think it looks okay I
don't think that white is as much here
if anything at all see threatening
discoveries maybe
but okay I can do that just cover c5 a
little bit better just angle not totally
sure what the point is my DA form and
maybe should have ate was on the agenda
anyway want to have it covered not ok so
don't still don't get it what does the
idea here taking a 50 sets objective ok
5 9 p-6 that dangerous now I can't
believe it or let's let's not be too
quick maybe we have something better I
don't I don't see it I'm sorry and have
to take it even know Pusha where three
is no move unfortunately
yeah my rooks look funny but I don't
think objectively speaking I'm just born
up I guess always the big idea i had
simply don't see it so where'd you go 27
maybe on
okay we'll see one maybe then at the
time is the biggest problem position is
fine
at least I don't see anything terrible
happening to me
how do I entangle this though and K want
to prove the rook here the rukon a5 was
always kind of hanging k this one time
morning I don't have any time to figure
that out
check Oh mmm how would a shame check
check what is that I don't see it my
mate it night see a dot night c 8 is the
problem I take it where where's the maid
it's probably going to show me oh I'm
adjusted winning or what I don't see it
check check hmm okay yeah it was she
headed game okay yeah white white was to
learn resign or born down for nothing
very stupid he played a very very weird
gay me on the queenside mostly weakening
himself with a 5 and so on the only
thing I didn't do is to just win it I
mean okay your Bishop g2 is immediate
resignation yeah I was only thinking
briefly about this but this is what's
not working as the rook hangs and so
this one this time this disaster can
this is an idea okay with what I did I
mean I don't believe it okay so now we
can take only six now with the noid
which you didn't do again does that just
kind of in the position but this is the
weirdness now we create okay a nice
computer moose I didn't see that but he
also didn't and here black is just
winning he five this is far more
convincing even now I've got a pawn
bishop a and he's got bad pieces it's
just a lost position
okay I didn't see that and now it gets
kind of and kind of tricky and this
doesn't work doesn't work I have to go
Queen takes check 97 now would have won
okay and yeah I'm just winning again
yeah Queen five wins jacket also wins
idea for though yeah I've got 15 seconds
it's kind of useless you can do whatever
you want he's not getting checkmated
quickly yeah the whole position is kind
of equal I think I spend a couple of
moves there with the Queen but it's just
a fairly solid position he should just
stay I mean this is just an a5 is just a
bad move 26 sorry bishop t6 is also an
interesting option here given by the
engine and i would i like that yet yeah
i should really just just win the game
it's kind of a shame even if i'm not
seeing a group chief I've just this
should be good it's two pawns and a
great position for the exchange em go to
cut the two bishops and the rook is
still there i mean it's it's an act of
attacking peace it's not as good as root
g5 but it's so good haha that game that
game by me okay thanks for watching